[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんはおうちにゴート入ったことあり
ますでしょうか僕はあの
ストーカーの女性が入ってきたことがあっ
てちょっと警察沙汰になったことあるん
ですけども今のところ強盗とかそのやばい
人とか泥棒とか入ったことがないんです
けれどもさすがにこのはじめしゃちょーが
住んでいる3億円のお家
目立ちすぎている多分この静岡市僕が住ん
でる地域の人は間違いなく100人中
100人僕の家がどこか知ってますもう
終わりですもちろん安全のために大量の
監視カメラあるショックいろんな
セキュリティはガンガンにしてやるものの
もしくはセキュリティが故障していて何か
の下に強盗が入ってきたらもう
金品盗まれて大変大変Aもそれ僕も
立ち直れないと思うのでもうそう考えると
もう怖くて怖くて夜も眠れず早い2年と
いうわけで今回はこのはじめしゃちょーの
3億円のお家に
強盗を呼んでみたいと思います
ターゲットは
僕じゃありませんこの家を守る男誰かそっ
かに中野大地です僕仕事でお家にいない時
とか結構多いのでどっちかというと
ペンギンの大地君管理人の彼がどう対応
できるか果たして3億円のうちの金品お金
貴重品は守られるのかちょっと見ていき
たいと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで強盗の皆さんにお越し
いただきましたよろしくお願いしますお
願いします
皆さんは実際に強盗された経験はあります
かまだないどう
ほぼ
的には
黒ずくめで目元がわからない
ターゲットに見られても
警察の方に顔の説明がしづらい状況で来て
いただきました今日よろしくお願いします
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
もう大丈夫です
皆さん強盗さんたちの役目としては3億円
のお家なので
結構金品があるからということで
ターゲットにある現金全部出せっていう
要求をしていただきたいです実際に
ちょっとルート見ていきましょう
[音楽]
冒頭が靴を脱いでました
4階にいるのでそのまま上がってきて
ください
[音楽]
強盗招き入れとるやん
ターゲットこの部屋にいると思いますここ
でターゲットがミーティングしてるので
ここを襲撃していただいてどんぐらい
までちょっとよく分かってねえんだよ
[音楽]
2万1000円です
強盗対策してんだよねいつ入られてもいい
のにその最小限のお金で行動してるから
これ正しいですよ実はこれで
皆さんには2番1000円でやって
いただきたいと思います
たりしてて
会議が終わりました
[音楽]
わかります
なくしました
3万おい
熱い
すると
逆になんか撮影っぽくなった
確認して詰めて
全部なかったら早々に履けるみたいな
ちょっとガチ感出していきたいです
全力で襲撃していただけるとその
ターゲットが来ますので
セッティング
[音楽]
はい
わかりました
[音楽]
[拍手]
持ってかれた
[音楽]
強盗が入ってくる
訓練動画でした
訓練確かに思いっきり僕しか殴られた話
です
電話でも基本的にセキュリティがしっかり
してるんでまず
入ってくるルートはないのでそうですね
ありえないと思うんですけどももし仮に
ルートが甘くてもしかしたら
甘くて入ってきたというように
車にさせていただきました確かにねいや何
もできなかった怖かった怖かった
結構抵抗してて
感動したもん俺なんか
足りないですね
セキュリティ